les inventeurs de midi pyrénées on va
poursuivre notre série avec un
personnage un vrai il s'appelle léon
trudel
il vit dans le tarn c'est un passionné
du moteur électrique il a adapté à sa
voiture son motoculteur sa charrue ou
encore sa mobylette découvrez ce
personnage très attachant et gaieté bien
la fin du reportage
c'est un grand moment de télévision ne
faut pas oublier que cet homme c'est en
ruine et pour sa passion et mérite notre
respect ils garaient qu'avec olivier de
nous la méthode rudel c'est celle qui
permet à cette voiture électrique de
rouler plus exactement les 11 rue dell a
inventé voici une vingtaine d'années
déjà
le moteur électrique qui se recharge
dans les descentes
le moteur électrique méthode rudel
équipe également ces cyclomoteurs
méthode redel encore sur les
motoculteurs bricolé par les ans
et de belles performances ma foi du
motoculteur électrique sur ce sol qui
n'avait pas été labouré depuis au moins
un demi-siècle
medion soudaine n'est pas agriculteur
jusqu'à ce qu'il prenne sa retraite il a
eu une entreprise florissante de
charpente métallique est depuis toujours
qu'il est passionné d'électricité je
n'étais citée je connais je connais et
j'ai appris tout seul tout seul à
l'esprit je me suis appelé si le tas et
on dit que vous êtes très fort on dit
que vous êtes vraiment rajeunie de
l'électricité c'est vrai ça
l'électricité aurait tout pour rendre
les autres heureux s'il n'y avait pas ce
problème de brevet pour son moteur qui
lui coûtent des fortunes sans retour
financier jusqu'à maintenant
non il est pas content parce que je me
ring
combien vous payez d'oeuvre de pour les
brevets comme monsieur payet cmim
collègues va prendre l'appui des petits
détails
de plus québec et vous faites ça
parisiens un peu vous voulez lutter
contre la pollution et oui quand on
comptait peu surprenant que le personnel
les organes et et tout ça est déneigé
rien ne vaut la primaire et si paul et
ne dites surtout pas que la méthode
grenelle dans des moteurs mousse sans
aucune nervosité et bâillonnée
[Musique]